oh how do you pop Chris do you twist how
do you I mean this is not popping you're
doing backward oh yah oh hey guys we're
back in my kitchen and I don't know
about you but I am so tired of doing the
dishes I don't have a dishwasher just
have one of those drying racks so I have
challenged myself to try and cook a
three-course meal in one pan that's
right guys I'm gonna be doing an
appetizer and entree and a dessert all
in this pan I don't really don't know if
that's achievable but but it'll be fine
so let's give it a try and then we'll
get Chris in here to taste test Chris
you're gonna taste test so first thing
I'm gonna do is prep our appetizer and I
think jalapeno poppers would be perfect
I love the gooey inside the crispy
outside and then like just a little kick
of heat from the jalapeno so we'll take
one jalapeno and just cut him right in
half next we're gonna use a spoon to
remove the seeds and the insides of the
jalapeno the seeds are what make
jalapeno really really spicy and we're
gonna try to tone it down a bit and if
you don't have gloves don't worry just
make sure you wash your hands afterwards
and try to avoid touching the seeds as
much as possible when doing this go
ahead and repeat this on to other
jalapenos our final one is done I have
one more jalapeno left and this is gonna
be for a main course which is gonna be a
[Music]
so I'm gonna slice this into thin slices
so we can put it as a topping on the
pizza push these off to the side and
we're gonna stuff our jalapeno poppers
so I bought already whipped cream cheese
this way I don't have to put in a bowl
and kind of break it up with a fork less
dishes less fuss that's what we're all
about today so take about a tablespoon
of cream cheese per jalapeno boom I have
some bacon strips I've cut in half and
we're just gonna wrap those around the
jalapeno and try not to overlap the
bacon when you're wrapping this because
we want to make sure it cooks all the
way through especially since we kind of
have limited
amount of cook time we're dealing with
other elements don't overlap next thing
I'm gonna do is basically make like a
little foil tray for our jalapeno
poppers this way if any bacon grease
like Falls drips off it's not gonna seep
into our pizza or our dessert so I'm
gonna fold in two inches on one side and
I'm gonna fold in about two inches on
the other then you're gonna kind of dog
your the corner and fold the two sides
together all right my little tray is
complete I'm gonna put him in the corner
and we're gonna put our jalapeno poppers
inside cute I'm gonna go wash my hands
and we'll move on to our main course so
the next thing we're gonna make is pizza
and the reason I picked pizza is because
the dough bakes at around 425 and you
can cook the jalapeno poppers in the
bacon around the same temperature and
hopefully for the same amount of time
first thing I need to is open it which
is always I forget pop present peel pop
I'm just gonna try with my hand pop okay
pop how do you pop Kris do you twist how
do you I mean this is not popping you're
doing backwards oh yeah oh get out get
out in a while oh he's open I'm gonna
oil my pan and then we're gonna lay out
our pizza dough okay next step we're
gonna do is I have a can of marinara
sauce here and I'm gonna use that as my
pizza sauce this is totally customizable
you could even do a pesto base for this
or an alfredo base next we're gonna
sprinkle with some mozzarella cheese
we're not using fresh mozzarella on this
because we don't want to give that
moisture to leak out and again get on
our dessert and I love a little
pepperoni on the pizza so I'm gonna do
about 12 slices here last but not least
I'm gonna add some jalapeno slices on
here for a nice green color and I just
like a spicy a spicy pizza she looks so
good I got a chill out I got calmed down
but I just didn't know you could do this
all on a panda I mean at least till I'm
celebrating a little too early I don't
know if it's actually even work I'm so
excited about what we're gonna try for
dessert so let's go get all the stuff
for that and I'll be right back
the last thing I'm gonna whip up is a
s'mores pie I love s'mores so much
reminded me of camping reminds me of
summer but instead of using pie crust
I'm going to use puff pastry puff pastry
generally bakes at 400 degrees which is
perfect for a pizza dough and our
jalapeno poppers with the bacon
so first thing we're going to do is
lightly flour our surface here we'll set
our puff pastry on top we're not gonna
roll this out very much we just want to
get rid of the creases so we're gonna
measure out a six by eight rectangle and
then you can say this puff pastry and
use it for something else
another little quick dessert next I'll
score a half inch border around the
rectangle make sure you don't go all the
way through the puff pastry if you're
doing this at home so the last thing we
need to do to prep our puff pastry
it's a docket with a pork and this is
going to allow steam to escape and keep
the bottom from puffing up while the
outside will grow much bigger
this looks great I'm going to transfer
this to our pan next thing we're going
to add is
little bit of a hazelnut chocolate
spread and you'll just take that and
you'll spread it all along the base
sprinkle some marshmallows on the top
this is gonna give you that roasted
marshmallow camping taste
we take graham cracker of towards and
we're just gonna coarsely crush this up
so you just two second does it need to
be fancy one last thing we have to do
and I don't have it ready hold on a
pastry brush a black thing you need to
do is brush the edges of our puff pastry
with a little bit of egg wash this is
just gonna give it a nice shine and
golden brown color not the healthiest
dinner but a fun one so I'm gonna go put
this in the oven at 400 degrees for
about 20 to 25 minutes watch it like a
hawk and hope that everything cooks
perfectly together
fingers crossed all right wish me a lot
it actually worked
I'm so excited it's the last thing we're
gonna do is add a little bit of garnish
for the pizza I'm gonna take some fresh
basil I'm gonna do some torn and some
whole pieces we're gonna add a few more
marshmallows to our s'mores pie and
we're gonna break up one more graham
cracker and then I've melted about
three-quarters of a milk chocolate bar
into the microwave and I'm just gonna
kind of zigzag that across the top it'll
help keep our marshmallows down and our
graham crackers down CREB
Chris I have made a three-course meal
whoa just one pan first up we've got
jalapeno poppers as our appetizer
delicious for your main course is a
pepperoni pizza ooh and is that some
spice I see on there isn't some fresh
basil and then just finish the night we
have a delicious s'mores pie
this looks really really good let's
let's make our plates mint okay ready
okay you know what's really good about
that
try your lovely pizza and eggs okay my
fresh basil it's really good okay can we
have the dessert yeah it's more of an
experience than it is it's an urban
experience right you I am you I love you
too oh wow so much chocolate sorry all
right what movie should we run uh
something like that takes place in a
period piece how about the history of
soup
No
[Music]
you
[Music]